I don't think I knew exactly what
dressing modestly actually truly meant
until the first time I wore the
swimsuits that I would need to wear
and it was a very profound moment for me
because it all like the reality of it
became
very clear
and and very fast
[Music]
is this it yeah
not long after I married him Wahoo and I
were at the Red Sea and there were a lot
of tourists wearing bikini or just like
a one-piece suit whatever just normal
I remember feeling
jealous like that was how I used to be
and I've been like kind of taken from
that life and then
this is my new life and I'm just not
used to and I don't like it that much
you know I don't like I don't like to
wear that
I still have a lot of anxiety about
wearing this swimsuit today but I'm
doing this for Mahmoud
[Music]
so this is a bikini I'm choosing not to
wear the hi gab part of this uh bathing
swimsuit because uh I don't wear a gap
I'm not going to wear a gab and I won't
wear a gap I don't cover my hair
[Music]
I'm a love
you decide to wear this one
yeah you fail
yeah it's weird I like the tops I love
you I get to look so cute and everything
you look so cute amazing really and my
hooded bathing suit
really you look amazing
and thank you so much
[Music]